[Applause]
[Music]
my real name is Brad Pitt was born with
it Brad Pitt's Hollywood Evolution you
know you're in good hands from the then
literally loaded up the car didn't
graduate to the now well you're you're
in the no and everything in between the
debauchery and the chaos and everything
else goes with it et's never before seen
interviews I see my mom kind of go and
go living behind the scenes of his
biggest films plus what you never knew
about his romances so I got engaged
that's one of the greatest moments of my
life and bromances I steal hearts all
our best moments with Brad slave to
Fashion baby I'm a slave to Fashion
let's have some fun before we go out
this is ET Vault unlock Brad Pit on
fire the man is Benjamin Button on
screen and off happy 60th birthday to
the one and only Brad Pit welcome to
Entertainment Tonight oh yeah he's a
movie star with a capital M and A
capital S so let's move this party to
the ET Vault and unlock all the reasons
we are mad about
Brad when do you think you pass the
Baton to these young guys oh I'm already
I've already passed the Baton I've
always said it's a younger person sport
it's the Natural
Evolution there's a shelf life on this
thing and hopefully we have other things
going for us yeah Brad just gets better
with age we see you with those Fight
Club Vibes let's not forget he has
nearly 90 acting CR credits that have
brought over1 billion worldwide not to
mention two Oscars and an estimated net
worth of $400 million oh just some guy
Brad's transformation from Thelma and
Louise boy toy to Hollywood's Golden Boy
had cemented his spot in cinematic
history here's my real question we're
the same age how come you still have all
that damn
hair I don't know but I got other
problems we we'll talk
afterwards we love how this debonaire
extraordinaire has always exuded a cool
confidence that has also made him
beloved amongst his Hollywood peers and
I'll tell you this we're not running
anymore there's a familiarity that comes
with the two of us and I think that
certainly in the instance stop looking
at me of playing these characters why
are you so handsome my dad was a
weatherman he asked you know for help I
show up I ask for help he shows up I
love you so much he's a pack horse and
and he's gorgeous and he you know loves
women and I just I love being with him
Brad of course has a history of dating
some of his leading ladies will you tell
me more about
California yeah I guess so Brad and his
California co-star Juliet Lewis were an
item from 1989 to 1993 absolutely none
of your business the following year he
began a three-year romance with his
seven co-star Gwyneth paltro get it got
it Brad co-starred in two films with
x-wife Angelina Jolie first Mr and Mrs
Smith then by the Sea you get married
and all of a sudden you go off and do
this dark play a couple on the brink of
disaster then during the pandemic Brad
brought some much-needed Joy to the
country with his Emmy nominated SNL
appearance as Dr fouchy good evening I'm
Dr Anthony fouchy Brad shot the segment
inside his Hollywood Hills home so how
did the spoof come to be well SNL
reached out to Brad's team after this
which actor would you want to play you
oh Brad Pit of
course another unexpected Cameo Brad
popped up doing the weather on John cin
some good news Brad how's it looking out
there looks uh pretty
good yeah during the pandemic Brad also
picked up a new hobby we know you love
pottery making Pottery where did that
come
from it was like it was lockdown you
know we were all like what do we do with
ourselves and I just picked up a couple
of arts and crafts but when it comes to
Brad's acting craft that all started in
the80s you go yeah once you pop you just
can't stop shirtless Brad has been a
thing ever since this Pringles ad but
did you know Brad's first ever movie
role was also shirtless as a background
extra in 1987's appropriately titled
hunk a dream come true for the guy who
dropped out of college and moved to LA
with just 275 bucks in his pocket
literally loaded up the car didn't
graduate I didn't finish all I had to do
was hand in a turn paper but in my head
I was done I was going west and and
within a week I was doing extra work and
really really
happy the first TV thing was either
Dallas I hope you won't be doing any
drinking no sir I'd never do that or 30
something where I had one line hi hi
shirtless or in a basketball jersey or
as the cute new guy at school in Growing
Pains I sound like James Dean in Rebel
Without a Cause Brad was already on his
way to heartthrob status even star in
opposite Johnny Depp in 21 Jump Street
you really been to jail yeah but his
road to superstardom wasn't always easy
I was extra in a Charlie Sheen film oh
business business you know how it is
there a big dinner scene at at a
restaurant and they had me pour the
champagne in the glasses and I thought
I'm going to try to get a line in then I
got to this actress at the end and I
poured her drink and then I looked at
her and I said would you like anything
else she looked at me and went I had the
first idea he goes cut cut cut cut cut
and it came over to me so you do that
again you're off the set I was like oh
man oh man Brad's big rle started coming
in the 9s and that's when ET first sat
down with him how old are you me 38 22
14 I don't know so how does Brad feel
about seeing himself just 26 years old
we have that here for you and I want you
to hear what you said what I say my real
name is Brad Pit yeah I have big goals
everyone wants to be taking seriously
to an extent see basically I thought I
knew what I was talking about no but I
like that do you feel like Mickey Ro
films I got the Mickey Ro bandana going
of course Brad's breakout role was in
Felman Louise take that cash you put in
that bag right there you got an amazing
story tell you friend it's tough one
Elman Louise and there's little Gina
Davis rolling around SC right I see my
mom kind of
go it's a living he arrived to the
premiere with Ben girlfriend Juliet
Lewis throughout the Brad landed 17 film
roles yes that really is Brad singing in
Johnny Suede and remember Brad in cool
world it's the man with the badge in the
flesh Fight Club Legends of the Fall
Interview with the Vampire and A River
Runs Through It solidified pits place as
a hot leading man well I'm sorry about
that that was my fault your name comes
up on the screen and the squeals just
start I mean who's going to complain
playing are you kidding me I mean listen
you go through all the high school try
to get that when Brad started dating
gwenneth palro the two sh did like to
match weren't you married William oh TR
by 1996 Brad popped the question yes I
got engaged that's one of the greatest
moments of my life when I talked to her
she said I want a lot of kids I guess
I'm going be a dad with a lot of kids
they never ended up getting married and
Brad wouldn't become a dad until
Angelina but he did close out the decade
dating the friend who would become his
first wife speaking of friends this guy
named uh George gor gor Jorge Clooney
he's very nice guy hi huge fan huge huge
huge fan it was 2001 When Brad first
worked with fellow a-lister George
Clooney in Oceans 11 kicking off a
Hollywood Bromance for the ages been
practicing this a little bit did I rush
it felt like I Rush was good I liked him
he was being the dutiful newlywed on the
phone with the wife every night it's not
that complic at really talking on the
phone with my wife or hanging out with
this guy Jennifer Aniston or me former
sexiest man alive these guys have a lot
in common they are actually both two
time sexiest men alive both two-time
Oscar winners and of course they both
love to roast each other we all really
like each other we get along except for
Brad who's the biggest diva in this
group Brad George there's plenty of
reason to hate him let me tell you turn
that camera off and I'll tell you some
stor ETS had a front row seat to their
decad long prank filled friendship no I
just stayed home I did a lot of
[Laughter]
reading I put out a memo with a don't
look me in the eyes and help me with my
character by calling me only Mr
ocean two days later walk around the
passenger side of my car and there's a
big sticker that says small on board
would you guys want to do a
13 absolutely no no no chance no unless
we could just do it without each other
but 3 years later it's
latest the oceans Trilogy raked in over
a billion dollars at the box office the
dynamic duo starred together again one
year later in Burn After Reading and
this year the longtime Pals were spotted
on set of their upcoming Thriller wolves
my goals in life now are pretty simple
just not get into a financial situation
where I have to do oceans
14 the truth is I just really enjoy
being around him and can you believe
them all wanted me to throw this away
who are the most handsome men in the
world past and
present well I got to name that George
Clooney another handsome co-star Brad
loves to give public props the Oscar
goes
to Brad
Pit Leo I'll ride on your coattails any
day man I would have shared the
raft never let go Brad earned a Golden
Globe and his first acting Oscar working
alongside Leo in Quinton Tarantino's
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
hey good friend
Cliff I try Brad and I as soon as we
steep into these shoes it was one of the
more easy sort of natural fits that I
think I've ever
experience here I come oh he's a good
egg and I'm really happy the restraining
order was lifted off of me and so we
were able to work again and then there's
Bradley Cooper Brad credits him with
changing his life I got sober because of
this guy and every day has been happier
ever since I I love you and I thank you
guys got to go to
work you guys said you wanted to get
rich now you're rich really takes a lot
of pushing a lot of nurturing it for
years and years to get it there I'm
really proud of the work The Big Short
Moneyball oaka they're all Brad Pit back
movies the Stars Plan B production
company has earned 3 billion at the box
office globally ET first talked to Brad
about being a producer 20 20 years ago
when he pulled double duty on Troy it's
it's a whole another aspect of our of
our business you know um just developing
the story immortality take it it's
yours have you always been that
comfortable with your own body no no no
I have my own vanity and I have my own
you know things I'd want to change the
Ben 39-year-old gained 20 lbs of muscle
for the roll quit smoking and yep even
tore his Achilles attendant Achilles
hurts Achilles yeah stupid stupid Twist
of stupid irony but looking like a Greek
god paid off the film made nearly $500
million at the box office to move these
Summer Films because of their size they
all take a little more effort boss Brad
also had a producer credit on World War
Z his biggest Blockbuster to date he
backed Eat Pray Love with longtime pal
Julia Robert blonde starring Anna De
armis Plan B and Brad um have been very
very supportive I don't think we would
be here today without them and we can't
forget films like The Departed Moonlight
and 12 years of slave which all took
home Oscars for best picture we keep in
mind great stories and stories that need
to be told and stories that are relevant
for our time right
now hi Aniston hi pit how you doing good
honey how are you doing I'm all right
come on now even the stars were smiling
watching that happen Brad and Jen
reunited in 2020 at the star studed Fast
Times at ront high virtual table re I'm
still smiling about it but in order to
appreciate the journey we've got to
flash back through the past over two
decades earlier when Brad and Jen became
more than
friends true I tell you I love my
wife I love my life can I just say I
love Brad Pit I love
you the volume level when the two of you
arrived just elevated beyond belief
did it really the two were introduced in
1994 through their managers but it would
take four years for things to turn
romantic Brad and gwth paltro had ended
their engagement and Jen split with Tate
Donovan how long did it take you to know
I want to be committed to this guy to
that Brad the date that's all that took
we were pretty hooked after that July
29th 2000 200 guests including Courtney
Cox Cameron Diaz Salma hyek and David
Spade watched as the pair tied the knot
in a lavish Malibu wedding complete with
a reported $20,000 firework
display the newlyweds made their debut
six weeks later at the Emmys Brad
sporting a necklace with jyn's name on
it I'm really excited to be here thank
you and she's nominated yeah that's
right yeah I'm ecstatic the pair was
Hollywood's most successful couple Brad
had earned a reported 40 million the
year before and Jen was about to earn a
million per episode for friends we can
do it all we're we'll sleep when we're
80 all right
right bab hi Rachel and green God I hate
her Ross I Fe her it's all good it was
such a fun experience for us to work
together like that soon the two were
working together and of course this was
inevitable and frustrating when are you
going to have a
baby the world is waiting for you guys
to get pregnant well there's a room that
will eventually be filled with hopefully
a child Brad and Jen baby I can see it
now but in 2005 Brad and Jen called it
quicks relationships happen and they
happen for a reason and they're not
necessarily meant to go on forever and
you're supposed to learn certain things
from and work yeah Cut 2 2020 the A-list
X's made our wildest Hollywood dreams
come true with this epic reunion at the
SAG Awards what do you make of all the
Ridiculousness it's hysterical but what
else are they going to talk about the
same can't be said about Brad's
relationship with Angelina Jolie now
it's bitter cold despite starting red
hot in Mr and Mrs Smith satisfyed
not for years at first their romance
caused a tabloid frenzy team Jolie
versus Team Aniston but soon they were
minted Hollywood's it couple and always
candid about their six kids I don't know
how you can be gorgeous every time you
show up for these and have the kids
around the house all morning the dress
goes on last minute we've gone out peed
on without people
knowing yeah it's just Dad nothing's
cool nothing's cool with d anymore but
but this is why we do it you know this
why we do these just for the kids Brad
and takes things the kids make and turns
it into something like he made a blanket
one year of all their drawings in 2012
Brad popped the question and their kids
were already wedding planning they've
got a lot of crazy ideas and I'm sure
most of them will win out so yes they'll
they'll be the ones deciding the you
know when it comes and how it's done I'm
sure two years later they tied the knot
at their Winery in France Chateau
miraval Angie's Veil included sketches
by their kids how's married life it
doesn't suck the couple skipped a
honeymoon to go shoot their their second
movie together by the Sea the drama was
about a marriage on the Rocks cuz you're
jealous you're sick no we we had a few
uh weeks into it we wondered if it was a
good idea because it's heavy and it's a
lot of fighting soon it got ugly
offscreen too Angie filed for divorce in
2016 after an altercation on a private
jet where she claimed in an FBI report
Brad poured beer on her and was shaking
her Brad was cleared of any wrongdoing
they also waged a nasty legal War
against each other over their Winery and
custody of their children on
the these days Brad's been low-key about
his personal life for a little more than
a year Brad's been going strong with
jewelry designer inz de Ramon a source
tells ET things are going great between
them and they both make an effort to
keep their relationship private to
protect it let's have some fun before
before we go
[Music]
out yeah Brad popped up in that ad for a
luxury coffee brand maybe that's his
secret to looking angelist May me
thirsty all of a sudden did I say that
out loud you sure did I sure did but
yeah Brad is embracing his new chapter
as a Bonafide renaissance man good night
everybody I got one question what is the
reason for you that you took a a Kill
Tonight
Breeze
Breeze talking to Brad Pit about fashion
is a first you've been giving us all the
looks that's it man the Glam but also
the debauchery and the chaos and
everything else that goes with it Brad's
continuing his fashion trends through
his own clothing line God's true
cashmere the price tag to look like him
about 2,000 bucks slave to Fashion baby
with a glow to match he also has a line
of his own skincare products made with
grapes grown at his Winery just like his
ex Gwyneth paltro Brad admits the goop
founder was probably the first one who
got me to even wash my face twice a day
I'm really good at it
what